welcome to this video this is about the
start of the second lack of them I think
it's called the world cup final right
now the final masters I'm sorry there
are so many different masters finals and
cups it's difficult to keep track the
final masters masters final we are
whatever we on the second leg so it's
round six in this sound event first five
rounds have been played in Brazil in sub
Paulo and they took about one week to
relocate to blue bow now for the final
five games um get the first leg um had
seen caruana dominating the field with a
bit of luck you need to really take that
into account you wanna clear the worst
to lost position against cards net held
a really dead position against them
aronian which is nevertheless of some
something to be proud of you need to not
losing your lost positions is very
important virtue and it's a it's not at
all easy to keep up the resistance and
lost positions and get the the odds draw
here and there yeah this though it's
clear that this first game is essential
for the further cost the tournament as
cards in his playing car wanna with
white Carlton had lost this yeah this
weird first game in Brazil and he badly
needs to win this game to get into
contention to win this tournament so
let's see what happens carzon playing
1.e4 and corona surprisingly i'm going
for the french your the french has
played often in this tournament so it's
a bit surprising it's not surprising
considering that the French has some a
pretty good theoretical standing at the
moment but still it's surprising to see
on that level to see it plates often but
Carlton now plays to d3 avoiding all
kinds of theory
dakoda scallions um this is basically
telling Cara wanna okay we play chess
now from booth to and forget about any
computer preparation and I think pretty
early on we get into some position which
is yeah just played by the both players
and not prepared prepared unlock 85-90
to own and I'd have six Knight to f3 so
normal moves and in this kind of
formation black has a multitude of
possibilities you can play b6 which has
a pretty good reputation you can play
the classic move classical move c5 and
then now knight c6 we should be seven
our castles with witches may be a bit
risky it's probably ok but gives white
chances on the King side there are
multitude of possibilities Cara wanna
know place 96 which is also i think
believed to be a good move and the idea
is that black wants to exchange on e4
and then play e5 candle na place c3 this
is actually I'm yeah kind of a waiting
move anticipating what I just mentioned
if white would play g3 just to to put it
on the board which is often the idea if
you're chatting the bishop and black can
get into this kind of position where you
rather want your bishop to be on not
there hit it ok to want your bishop on
let's say c4 even eat ooh but not on g2
it's not terrible on g2 but it's just
better on one of those slide squares
here be 5c for one of these to play in
the sand on g2 it mainly bites on the e4
pawn so this is why white now delayed
some any commitment for this bishop and
now black plays Bishop to d6 yeah which
is a bit of a preparation move for
taking and playing e5 or in the game as
cm he plays a five straight away without
exchanging now I'm not sure I'm in this
movie so many okay what doesn't put any
pressure on like so it's certainly okay
this move there should be two castles
castles and a five yeah a five is
designed to prevent any before ideas on
my white it's a very very typical
movement in this structure note that why
does yeah playing something like a
reversed philidor its lucky 5d6 c6 and
just this setup here so why does not
exactly try to play and serve and volley
style winning quickly but rather get a
longer along the kind of maneuvering
battle which is really typical for cards
and style it doesn't really want to get
into a theoretical discussion but wants
to play chess went through those guys so
rookie one which is some of course
useful clearing f1 for any kind of peace
and may be preparing e5 black plate if
I've now himself yeah now it's
interesting the question is what about
this paw information in the center would
like exchange here or will why the
exchange on d5 which is also interesting
in fact cousin plate this capture and
change the bond formation he went not to
c4 with the night and now this night put
some pressure on the center and can also
add one one point or another captcha on
d6 getting the bishop am still on the
bishop pair wouldn't be so yeah so great
for white as the bishops are not doing
so much at the moment but let's see what
happens rookie aid and Bishop to to f1
yeah this is a typical maneuver here
securing the bishop on f1 and allowing
some increased pressure on the pawn on
e5 of course why doesn't have any
advantage but this wasn't I'm Carla's
idea he just wants to play a longer game
and don't want sir and I know some
prepared line which gets ya which
somehow I'm removes our life from the
position and it certainly manages there
are pieces of our pieces are on the
board it's not great for white but you
get get a longer and longer fight ok
Bishop g4 is read the source very normal
bishop age five and now g3 yeah this is
designed to probably prepare Bishop g2
at some point simply because them get
this pin is so so annoying cannot them
live in the spin all the time with the
Queen so we need to cover the same night
that you don't want to return to g to e
2 so after all white is preparing a
fianchetto but like a now plate 96 and
then that changes things a bit I think
white was thinking about as mentioned
just am redeploying the bishop and
playing and playing on in this in this
kind of position but not be six it's
very crude of course black yeah
threatens to take on c4 and so why down
needs to react and yeah it's a similar
reaction he just took it on b6 and black
recaptured yeah this is in fact an
interesting decision by Kara wanna to
allow the support structure I think he
didn't really young consider this kind
of information on a huge weakness but in
instead them counted on ideas like
Bishop c5 and this way of getting some
pressure on the deep on but then in fact
it really weakens the Queen side and we
will see in the the course of the game
that this has consequences like it
didn't really need to play the sun night
bc
he had other Lucy could oops not this
for example he could have played
something like this to prevent any any
Queen sorties ok it was not threatening
at the moment because of the hanging
night but I mean a far is also pretty
normal looking move with this position
ok but he went as mentioned for this
Knight b6 thing and here I move it with
this surprised me a bit what Carlton
plate he ever say he played Bishop g2
but I think this is designed to keep the
fight going my initial reaction would be
you to play a 4 here too oops yeah it
clicking no I want to get rid of this
green square how do I get rid of this
it's not working ok I wanted to click on
this yet somehow it doesn't remove the
green square maybe if I if I am put it
again yeah this is better and I would
play a form in order to fix this
weakness but luck has this Bishop c5
move and also this is not the end of the
story Bishop c5 let's say white
continues here and then you've get this
move and yeah we are really weak on the
deep on so a four losses some yeah
moving in a way and how do you protect
this now probably with this move and
then black can can simply return it ask
you how do you continue now so maybe a 4
is a bit too slow in the game Carlton
play Bishop g2 immediately to to get
this neither protected and allowed like
to play be five but as we see this isn't
such a big deal on b5 you just played a
form and yeah what should like do now he
am advanced alternative Tok can think
about capturing but this is certainly
also um gap
a bit bit uncomfortable Queen B 5 really
clicking badly today Queen B 5s the
problem now which would irritate the the
whole Queen side this is simply weakness
this is all caused by this Knight b6
move which really am put some obligation
on like to pray prism to play a
precisely on the queenside and this is
why I'm not so sure about this same
maneuver okay he played a B form and the
cars are just played we should be three
so I'm are quite quite logical and
Bishop to c7 yeah also very logical move
getting some pressure on the D porn
probably preparing to play we should be
six exchange further material and you
contemplate queen to be three yeah the
idea is really it's really this this
kind of route to put pressure on the
queenside and of course that's not all
of it is also sending a little trap but
then of course tarana was on top of
things black cannot take on d3 now
because of the simple move rogue 81 and
where do you go now if you go to a 6
there's even the funny move Bishop f1
and you cannot really save the queen
Queen gets gets trapped funny finally
with it the funny fish of this two
bishops so cannot go here and yes stuff
like that simply loses the bishop you
have three pawns but it's still a
terrible position as why just everything
on good on good sir squares so maybe
just to continue at the bit let's let's
say here and you've got here and strong
diagonal Isis is not not playable at all
for black him and some pretty pretty
lost really so I cannot you cannot take
on d3 of course but yeah what should
black play now it's not easy at all
para wanna played h6 taking this square
under control which is understandable
because nadji 5 was was an idea and lots
of variations variations so it's an
understandable and garden up when done
quinta see form in fact instead of
Quincy for you had a very interesting
alternative with 9h form this move is
not so easy to understand it first but
it's it's quite strong the ideas that
done yeah white might go to f5 at some
point but it's it's a kind of the case
of that thread is stronger than the
execution of what would actually do this
it wouldn't do him so much good because
of yeah let's a bishop to g6 but one
problem is also that black has problems
moving his pieces because in some cases
white just plays g-form and this bishop
doesn't have any any decent square let's
say let's say queen dsm just for
argument's sake then g4 is a problem for
black of you go back you'll simply lose
this bishop because of this this pin on
the diagonal I of course black can do
tricks like this say I'm now attacking
the night but just look at this kind of
position this simply looks good for
white you have weakened yo yo King
position a bit but you have really
really active pieces now all in the
center so this night h4 was interesting
I mean but causal played a queen to c4
which is according to plan he wants to
get this into play and of course this
protects the bond yeah it's a good
multi-purpose move um yeah and now I'm
you will see a really a key a key point
in this game what corona is doing now is
some initiating force sequence which
leads into an end
game and its really questionable if this
was a good decision um what the
alternatives did he have I mean a decent
move I think would be Bishop to g6 it's
also very obvious to check the pawn and
then you can think about something like
this I don't know just just more let's
keep the position but White has de for I
just recognize this it's also not not
nice at all yeah I mean I think really
this Knight b6 move which somewhat
crippled the queenside was bad it really
was a bad decision I mean white is
better in this position here it's just a
question of how much better and not if
um it's just a matter of is it a slight
advantage big advantage so how to tell
maybe he can play this year all right
look at this position yeah just just
just put it on the world White has
pressure he's got did long this diagonal
this kind of ideas and it's simply a bad
structure black cannot move any of this
pawns and the queen is strong on b5 now
it doesn't really it doesn't really
improve okay what can I did end nothing
this was planned beforehand i miss
transpose into this end game that we
that we get now it's a long sequence he
took on c3 which only really makes sense
and connection to the following yeah the
following sequence because otherwise
this mover would would simply be
terrible to open up the beep I'll be far
I mean maybe this whole sequence is
terrible but it's a it's very difficult
to assess in comparison to the middle of
game positions I think he should have
gone for more of a middle game position
but it's difficult let's see what
happens just to show what I'm talking
about he played efore now and Carlton
just took it I mean he was suddenly he
suddenly liked them the end
game that that is coming up in fact you
had an interesting middle game
alternative but this is a bit of a
computer move from this 90 form and then
the point is that if black can sense 95
which is the the immediate idea you have
queen bee 5 and this is some quite good
for for white but it's really difficult
to assess for a human especially if you
take into account that the alternative
what cards are played leads to a
completely one-sided and pretty young
yeah yeah pretty bad end game from like
the idea of all this is black cannot
take here because simply this Bishop is
hanging and if you would take with the
pawn then there's f4 and you have a
similar issue but ok you you don't win
you don't win outright it's not not the
case like and can play other stuff you
can take here for example and then white
would probably a capture followed by
this and dumb why does some somewhat
better I think but it's not so clear if
this is better than what what was played
in the game let's look what happened the
game Carlton just took on your phone and
now Bishop takes f3 this was the whole
idea Bishop takes Bishop takes n95
walking the two pieces Queenie to you
need to cover this this Bishop of course
and now black took and played 23 this
was the whole idea of of the sequence
attacking this this pawn on on you find
getting it back yeah now Carla played
the simple but strong move kingi to
asking black okay how I would you would
you like to get this porn back
and he took with the Queen let's check
whicli if you would take with the rook
yeah then that's rook rook to d1 and
probably rook to e7 and this is really
annoying f7 and the seventh-ranked this
ruckus is strong on the seventh all
right so he cannot take with the rupiah
it he took in the game he took took only
four with the Queen I also note that you
cannot go here rook c1 and you you lose
the bishop alrighty took only for this
was the idea all along and now wide
plate the simple but very strong move
Bishop to deform yeah Black has no
choice he needs to to take on a three
and exchange queens of course you need
to check quickly what happens on Queenie
one the problem is that in this position
it's simply a double attack and black
loses the bishop so you cannot cannot
take on e 1 and black has basically no
choice he needs to exchange Queens and
King f3 yeah and this is the end game
that I was talking about Kara wanna on
move 19 yeah so it moves to go basically
went for this end game here in this
position when he took on c3 this was the
decision to go into the end game and he
certainly saw this this position here
and needed to assess this and this is a
very interesting position to to assess
and yeah not only for human being we're
also trying to yeah look at this with
the computer with an angled engine it's
pretty interesting to see that the
engine we can also um should you put the
next moves on the world yeah let's let's
just keep it this way that the engine
actually the engine wants to play the
same move that car wanna try b6 you
cannot go without b6 in the long run
that the engine ssssss
yes um if you let it calculate I'm
engine a min edenia right the top engine
it's um if the only gives white the
advantage of 0.2 so a fifth of a pawn
and this is quite curious really in them
if you compare this to a human
assessment I mean even when I looked at
this position I thought that white has a
pretty clear advantage I wasn't sure if
it's enough to win the game but it's
pretty clear that white is white is
better and also significantly better and
I was a bit surprised that the the two
Grand Master commentators on icc and
this was um volusia nicole bein of the
US and saucer look of turkey both are
very strongly GM's like two to six
hundred so they both thought that black
is very close to being lost already
against the kind of technique that that
cars in Assam is displaying and yeah
this I mean lost is really hard but it's
it's very difficult for black um yeah
why is this end game so bad for black
that they are there there are two
factors are not even to it there are
three factors even and this is why I'm
also amazed that the computer gives
white only such a slight advantage okay
one point these pawns are fixed on dark
squares and this is of course some huge
advantage for white who always has the
pressure on the b6 pawn and black just
has this bad bishop to defend the pond
this is the first advantage on the
second advantages and this is somewhat
connected to to the pawn structure is
that white has a beautiful and secured
bishop on our d form which is optimal
place three it's a great great position
for the bishop
putting pressure on the King son and of
course on the sensitive pawn on d6 and
this Bishop is much worse in comparison
it just text nothing and it's not easy
to activate it on and it doesn't have a
secure square at all I mean if this
position just theoretically if white
would have his bishop on deformed be to
we are and this would be on c5 then this
would be a completely different
assessment yeah it's a huge difference
in peace activity and the third
advantage that white has is obviously
the king he's on f3 already and he has
chances to in wait all the way back to
up to see six young and black is on g8
and it's not so easy to see how he would
get his King into play quickly so these
are this some these are three advantages
in this position and usually if you say
I'm white has advantages you can also
talk about blacks weaknesses and very
often it is the formula is if you've got
one weakness you can defend the position
if you've got two weaknesses it's often
yeah impossible to the event defend the
position and three weakness this is yeah
very often just too much and this is
three weaknesses yeah that's in its
mustard it's not only a static weakness
like the poor Nia but also the weakness
of the bishop which is weaker than
defined white Sun a superior King
position so this is definitely critical
for black um and I was surprised it's a
computer only gives us a 0.2 even after
like two or three minutes calculation
time yeah there's still hope for mankind
I think really a good technical player
like Arsenal kramnik would beat the
computer in this position very very
often
um all right so let's see what happens
it's still not not an easy winner
something but you will do that see let's
see what happens carleton place rook a
v1 by the way you could ask yourself
what about this b6 movement isn't it
silly as I just pointed out this is a
weakness the problem is if white plays
rook a b1 and he would he would do that
in the next move anyway then there's no
way to defend this point so you need to
play this anyway so b6 and says you know
it's okay rook a b-1 rook c8 yeah black
and relies on on some counter play on c3
so if white would take now on be
successes of course um this of course
nonsense because I had even blunder sir
bundles apiece yeah silly even even like
this but he wants to get some some play
on on the C porn this is one idea so
rook c8 and now looking for and this is
a very strong and very annoying move for
black it's not doing so much in itself
but it's a it's a problem what should
like to as long as this ruckus only form
their ideas like rook g4 for example
attacking g7 and yeah the rook on the
farm by playing rookie for white
actually allows this rukon b12 to move
probably to be five just to be more
flexible he couldn't play rugby five
with rook on a one obviously as he one
is hanging so he just increased the
mobility of the b1 rook a playing rookie
form and the problem is what should like
do to him to make any kind of progress
here and with whites ideas like Group B
5 hanging over over his head all the
time so it's difficult to keep the
tension he tried to he played g6 sort of
um yeah removing this point from a tech
of the bishop
and now why play G for a very
interesting aspect here of this end game
is um and it's very useful rule to to
look at if you have an end game and you
try to assess this end game one idea
often is to check which site actually
has got any kind of porn breaks of ideas
for it one advancing pawns to gain space
if you look at this position you will
see that black absolutely cannot move
any of his pawns it's simply not
possible if you would play h5 let's say
blacks to move young you play h5 just
for example then the end then your
problem is that ok this is enroute g1
but let's say take here h5 is simply a
deadly witness this is this will get
lost you can never play h5 basically in
this position play g5 you chronically we
can all your squares here and you put
further pawns on the dark squares which
you don't want again this Bishop and f5
vf5 is just suicidal opening the
position completely and black cannot
move any of his phones while why it has
got ideas he can push you for g5 you can
push the f porn later we will the world
see soon how white is able to make
progress and blackest is not so what did
he play actually you played require king
of it and now h4 has mentioned white
gain space and white won't supply h5
because it it puts another pawn on a
dark square and possibly white can even
put the bishop on e3 attacking h6 and b6
simultaneously and note that the bishop
on c7 which is the counterpart has no
position on the board to defend both
weaknesses so black needs two pieces to
defend two weaknesses and while white
only needs one piece to attack those so
this in itself is a huge advantage so 80
five is really a threat an idea that
white um can use to put further pressure
on black he now faltered and took only
four I think it's very difficult to keep
this tension and yeah you probably need
to take at the point and and I don't
really see a good alternative I mean if
you let's say black passes he and
doesn't do anything rugby aid then this
then there's this h5 idea and that's
mentioned possible Bishop to e3 now
cannot get rid of this solve this this
kind of stuff attacking the two
weaknesses and black simply as some is
it's simply a problem what what should
like do to defend this it's really an
absolutely terrible kind of endgame
where you're being tortured all the way
so I think it was really a bad decision
to go into the send game but it's often
very difficult from a psychological
point of view it's very difficult
because cara wanna certain you would
love to play a draw in this game and he
he didn't really could stand the tension
to to keep the position as it as it was
I mean slightly worse but probably not
not so terrible and instead he went for
this end game which he now needs to
defend and it's yeah it's a no fun at
all certainly okay he took on e form
King takes rook e8 check and King King
back to d3 if he ever I Whitewood what
did once then Blackwood player it's very
similar what doesn't gain so much by by
putting the King here he had some some
other idea and
let's see what do what he played played
to d3 rook to e6 and now we should be
three dimensioned double the tech like
covered and now look b5 this is the idea
that i was talking about activating the
rook on the fifth rank and this is why i
didn't put the king on d5 you wanted to
have the rupee and this is also very
nice you can see now the point I was
making earlier that black cannot move
any of his pawns g5 losses upon h five
losses upon f five losses upon and f6 is
yeah it's simply pointers it doesn't do
anything it just puts another porn on a
dark square while white can play f4 f5
h5 theoretically you could play g5 but
this is of course a bad move but this
looks fun yeah I should solve this kind
of stuff sometimes it's a looks looks
like modern art of it let's get rid of
this so white has lots of ways to
advance and increase the pressure and
black cannot move anything so I'm really
a really great position for white see
what what happens black plate Bishop 28
h5 and its really in rachal if you give
this position to D Nia the best engine
on the planet on and my my computer is
not really am it's not really a week
yeah it's a pretty pretty quick quite
quad-core intel i7 whatever and it
simply it's just 0.3 and this position
is it's just absolutely terrible for
like and it's really remarkable but the
thing is if you if your it wants move by
move the evaluation goes down the
computer is simply not able to really
assess the yeah the magnitude of blacks
problems ok h 546 check king see form
check again yeah 175 that black simply
cannot do anything and you need to
defend all the weaknesses and now wyd
them even advanced the f porn yeah what
should like doom can just sit and wait
and five yeah here's here's an
interesting point you gave a check let's
check what happened if black would take
take on f5 okay I have simply recapture
of course and yeah now you can can look
at to move the black would try to yeah
get some kind of activity with the rook
then just clean c6 is winning the game
Bishop d8 we should to be six and gives
you simply win both pawns yeah it's um
it's a pretty easy win of course also
the King on c6 against the King on f8 so
all whites pieces some join the attack
am simply am simply terrible so you
cannot play an active move as widen
weights so you need to give the check
here and after this it's very difficult
to to find find any kind of move well
where do you go need to defend p6 yep
probably something like this and now
while them we'll look at them further
ways to improve his position their arm
there are ways you can um for example
think about them just for instance
something like this going to h 7 11 look
here so increasing pressure on the Kings
side and their multitude of ways to
increase this i'm also the soup on
advanced can can play role of course
this needs to be considered carefully if
you advance to see porn you would
exchange weakness but sometimes it's
necessary to exchange weaknesses of the
opponent if you create some direct
opportunities so for instance in waiting
on the queenside and winning in the a
porn at the end will justify the place
afore
c5 some black is simply am still in big
trouble here um I think of the invasion
you on the King side is one one problem
also I mean even even as an idea let's
say I need to get rid of the arrows I
give you a sample line whoops you want
and I say let's say black there's
nothing up just just doing nothing what
does what is the idea rook h7 maybe even
Bishop g7 enter and get in the pond yeah
like it says close to being paralyzed so
at the f5 he had the end he gave this
check and and simply ya hear me he kept
the position he didn't take on on m5h
wife Ruby one so the luca is redeployed
on the kingside king aid and now Magnus
checks changed on g6 and plate rook to
h1 and now we get to the point where the
engine is really seeing that black is in
trouble it wasn't too pessimistic before
funny enough um yeah simply age six is
hanging what is what is black supposed
to do he played King f7 and relying on a
little tricky fight will take he would
actually use the game as it since this
is a check am so cannot take immediately
on on on h6 but you don't need to you
have other other good good moves and in
fact just King b5 was played Luke 2d6
check and Kings he fall yeah and now I'm
it's pretty much out of moves form for
black age six is now really hanging and
what should you do he played them I
think it took Leah he took him um g5 is
the alternative that the computer is
given sill initially with the quite
decent evaluation but after liberal of
time it recognizes that just rupee one
wins forward even it's impossible here
for black to prevent King to be five and
rookie six just brutally exchanging the
rooks and then white wins All Blacks
bones v6 a five and probably even Bishop
f8 at some point might win age 60 it's
simply dead young like something like
this and this is just open yo yak just
take others aidid's h5 I'm sorry I'm
sorry you cannot take you need to need
to be a little bit more cautious sorry
yeah and then this idea is also in there
what was I overlooked them here by
taking you need to be be gosh is this
h5m and it's it's czechia check on on g1
so little trick so wyd needs to play a
move like this and win the tempo in this
way and black simply has no defensive
against winning those those pawns if you
do this now you really can simply take
as the specialist is controlling the
diagonal yeah and the the square on g1
so g5 also loses tuturu ki one so he
took on unknown f5 white recaptures and
this is now really a clear-cut winner
while you could argue that there's some
defense here and there or some
improvement this is just really winning
now black play Bishop to g8 and now f6
and this is the key point which wins the
game h6 is hanging now and black is
simply unable to to defend this pawn if
you go here then that's recurred to g1
like can not advance simply due to f7
end this pawn will will promote after
something like this so he actually needs
to go back and then this route g7 so
winning completely
um yeah this is why black took on f6 and
now look to h6 yeah and this is the win
now because your thumb the fret known f6
to take with the winning king important
game so need to move the bishop and this
actually wins both pawns and white has a
bishop end game with two pawns and t1
those weak bones on b6 and a5 weary yeah
very much in a corner cording to the
theme of the game while these points
were weaknesses yeah note that this is
the wrong um the wrong corner here for
the bishop so without the sea porn
actually this would be a draw but with
the sea porn it's a simple win what can
simply push the pause that's technically
really easy just advance the pawns to
maximum activity and now you use your
own King very easy and yeah this is the
last line of defense black needs to keep
the bishop p.m. and yeah you cannot play
c7 yes black simply takes and you have
here you ever think the notorious
stalemate with the drum not really fair
you and chance that this is a draw but
then it simply the rules fee so you
cannot play c7 but cousin just played
this move and yeah Kara wanna resigned
because this diagonal is simply too too
short for black white will play Bishop
d8 next move so let's say here we should
be aid and next move you push through
your porn on after they exchange you
will promote your phone so I really like
this game a great technical display by
Carlton it wasn't so difficult really I
guess for him he just placed those stuff
very young yeah it's it's very natural
to him to play this this great in a
great fashion also note the clock time
say he
playing this rather quickly he got 56
minutes left at the end what I wanna
only was down to six minutes I'm not
completely sure about the tag control it
it's clear that Carlton was able to play
this technical part of the game rather
quickly and for me the really the key
position in this game was um yet to we
are not be six I think I don't know I
think this is simply bit dubious to
weaken your pawn structure it the real
qiyam was here in this position where
Cara wanna I decided to take on on c3
yeah this B takes c3 move and which
initiated this um why this is working
which initiated this kind of
simplification and transfer
transformation into this really bad end
game and he really should have kept the
tension probably and and kibum yeah keep
playing with a full board why does I
think slightly better anyway but it
simply not the kind of one-way one-way
battle that he had to had to fight in
the game against the some yeah against
this better bishop on d4 Mia this kind
of position as mentioned with them
simply with the three advantages that
white has with the better Bishop better
pawn structure because of b6 and the
better King yeah really nice game I
think very well very worth yet said some
it's very useful to to look at this kind
of endgame because you you don't really
must trust your computer all the time
let's let's say mu you Yuri's just
theoretically would reach this kind of
position um and while you prepare for
some game and so the computer would lay
your 0.2 we have just very slight
advantage for white it's
basically a draw right and this is
suddenly not the case this position is
just terrible for like especially in a
practical game maybe the computer would
defend somewhat better but it's simply
it's simply not equal and even not 0.2
that's simply am pretty big advantage
for wide so computers are not not
perfect alright thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed the game I really did
young as I like this kind of technical
display some very very nicely done
thanks for watching